let's continue looking at our DB helper
the other important function that we
were required to fill in is the on
upgrade method this function gets called
when the database has already been
created but the version has changed a
version change or upgrade should signify
that the columns tables or general
structure the database has changed the
SQLite open helper knows the database
version has changed because the version
we pass in to its constructor has
changed make sure to always change the
database version when you make changes
to the database tables you might think
why would I care about this
I'm not upgrading anything yet so why
bother because it's important to make
sure that your application won't have
errors when you make changes to the
database tables since we are going to be
using our database as a cache for web
data and not for user-generated content
will drop the tables which deletes all
of the data if the data had contained
information that was user-generated of
course we'd want to preserve it to do
that we'd likely use alter table to add
new columns see the instructor notes for
more information on alter table if you
were interested in how this is done